التقى اياه لاول مره وجها لوجه كريئيسين
لقاء ظاهره ود وترحاب وباطنه خلاف وتوتر
جزيره بالي الاندونيسيه جمعت الرئيسين
الامريكي جوبايدن والصيني تشي جين بينج
على هامشي قمه مجموعه العشرين وتاتي
المحادثات في وقت وصلت فيه العلاقات بين
البلدين الى ادنى مستوى لها منذ عقود مع
خلافات بشان مجموعه من القضايا تشمل
تايوان والتجاره ركزت المباحثات بطبيعه
الحال على ملفات تايوان واوكرانيا
والطموحات النوويه لكريا الشماليه وهي
ايضا من القضايا البارزه خلال قمه مجموعه
العشرين بعضن استهلا الاجتماع بتاكيد سعيه
الدائم لابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه مع
الصين على المستويين الشخصي والحكومي
مشيرا الى ان العالم ينتظر من البلدين
تدليله الازمات وعدم تطورها الى نزاع
بينهما
نجود
[موسيقى]
الصين
اكس بوكس
همم
الصين والولايات المتحده مره عبر 50 سنه
حافله بالاحداث التاريخ هو افضل كتاب لذلك
علينا ان نستفيد منه العلاقات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده حاليا تمر بحاله تدفعنا
للاهتمام بها ولا تصب في مصلحه بلدين
وشعبين وليست ما يتوقعه من المجتمع الدولي
لاننا قائدين لاكبر دولتين في العالم
علينا ان الصيغه الطريقه المناسبه
للعلاقات لايجاد الاتجاه الصحيح للعلاقات
الثنائيه مستقبلا وتطوير هذه العلاقات
ومثل ما عبر الرئيس الامريكي عن راغبته
بتحسين العلاقات ابدا الرئيس الصيني
استعداده لتبادل الاراء مع الرئيس
الامريكي حول العلاقات المشتركه والمسائل
الاقليميه والدوليه واضاف ان العالم يتوقع
من الصين والولايات المتحده اداره
العلاقات الثنائيه بشكل مناسب
تحديات غير مسبوقه والعالم وصل الى مفترق
الطرق الى اين نمضي هذا سؤال يدور في ذهن
الجميع ويتوقع من الصين والولايات المتحده
ان تدير هذه العلاقات بالشكل المناسب
علينا ان نعمل مع كل الدول لبث المزيد من
الامل في السلم العالم والاستقرار
والتركيز على التطوير المشترك انا مستعد
لخوض نقاش صريح لتبادل الاراء معكم حول
مسائل ذات اهميه استراتيجيه في العلاقات
بين الصين والولايات المتحده والمسائل
الاقليميه والدوليه اتطلعوا للعمل معكم
سيد الرئيس لاعاده علاقتنا الى الطريق من
اجل مصلحتنا ومصلحه العالم
لكن حتى قبل ان يبدا الاجتماع بين
الزعيمين توقع مسؤول في البيت الابيض الا
يحقق الاجتماع وانفراجه دبلوماسيه وانما
قد يكون بدايه لاعاده ضبط العلاقه
الثنائيه اضاف المسؤول ان زياده التعاون
لن يؤدي بالضروره الى تقدم الجوهريا في
القضايا الشائكه مثل تايوان لكنه قد يفتح
قنوات الحوار في ظروف الصعبه وهو امر يحظى
بدعم من الحلفاء في المنطقه وتحديدا
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
قوله ان بايضا يريد التاكد من ان المنافسه
بين البلدين محدوده مع ايجاد قواعد واضحه
للعلاقه تضمن عدم انحراف
المنافسه بين واشنطن الى نزاعا او الصراع